[Applause]
the muted Applause hasn't got any better
from last week and it's no wonder
because the answers haven't got any
better either the first minister is
suggesting there may be additional
course audit Scotland were very clear
the 1.3 billion cost is not going to be
the final course it's going to be higher
and it turns out from that feeble answer
that didn't address the point the first
Minister has no idea what it's really
going to cost he is throwing public
money away when Frontline social care
services are in desperate need of more
funding the SMP could be investing to
improve these local Services instead
they're creating a bureaucratic
bureaucratic Nightmare and want a blank
check to do it already the SMP have
wasted 14 million pounds on this plan
they've spent 1.9 million pounds on
Consultants but the plans are not
advancing there are no signs of progress
and the legislation has been repeatedly
delayed so is the first Minister paying
Consultants a fortune to tell them what
everyone else knows his plans are
willful and they won't work
first minister
it is uh hardly a surprise that a
national care service plan that puts
Fair work at the heart of it that puts
sectoral bargaining at the heart of our
plans for National care services that
puts ethical commissioning at the heart
of our national care service is wholly
opposed by the conservatives
hardly a surprise to anybody in this
chamber hardly a surprise touch reunion
colleagues and hardly a surprise to the
people of Scotland and all of that why
are we bringing it a national care
service for we're bringing it Forward
because we know of the extreme
challenges that are faced by those
working in Social care because of
Workforce we know those that is the
biggest challenge that is faced by
social care providers and of course one
of the fundamental reasons for that
Workforce challenge is the hard brexit
imposed Upon Us by a UK government so
once again the Scottish government is
having to pick up the pieces thank you
having to mitigate the woeful decisions
made by a cruel Tory government and how
are we doing that yes we are of course
committed to spending the national care
service but we've also made sure there's
an additional 100 million pounds to
provide that pay uplift from April of
this year this represents a 14.7
increase for these workers in the last
two years I was proud to make when I was
Health secretary to make sure that there
was not just one not just two but three
pay uplifts for our adult social care
workers and we want to go further where
we can so we have committed to invest in
Social care right now to undo some of
the Damage Done by the conservatives
hard brexit and at the same time we are
absolutely committed to our plans for
our national care service that will
ensure Fair work is at the very heart of
any future care service
you wouldn't have guessed it from that
answer but it was actually a question
about spending almost two million pounds
on Consultants on this proposal that the
first Minister failed to address in his
answer but these plans are such a mess
that his social care Minister that he
Todd who sat in the chamber just now
said this this week
it's been a little bit hard for me to
get my head around
a bit hard for the Minnesota charge to
get our hay today in first Minister
she's talking about your plans because
before Hamza used to field upwards he
was not just the health secretary he was
cabinet secretary for social care he
wrote the shambolic plans so what does
it say about the first Minister's policy
if his own care Minister doesn't
understand it first Minister
it just goes to show how desperate
Douglas law says when he starts with
their personal attacks or me or did any
of my colleagues
not on the substance on the personal
attacks from a man who is of course the
least popular elected politician on
these islands by any poor estimation in
the entire account oh and the best
return Douglas Ross has members as I'm
catching you up you're still the most
unpopular leader elected politician in
this country by quite a country male
presiding officer Douglas Ross is on
consultancy spend because it is an
important uh point of course at the
Scottish government and our officials
are absolutely focused on making the
national care service work but it is of
course important that we bring in those
additional Technical and specialist
expertise that allows the Scottish
government to ensure that we make
progress on the legislation itself and
in terms of the finances around the
national Care Service which are very
legitimate question I've said of course
we will engage with trade unions engage
with local government and hopefully when
we reach a compromised position on the
national Care Service we'll come back
with a revised Financial memorandum but
I'm hardly going to take and neither
will any of ministers in my government
take any lectures on financial literacy
from Douglas Ross who demanded that this
government copy less trusted tax cuts
which would of course the Scottish
government
500 million pounds and caused economic
Partners to our Scottish public finances
sauce
this is absolutely hopeless from the
first Minister he said it was a
desperate tactic by me to quote his own
Minister and and listening to that
answer I'm pretty sure Marie Todd still
can't get her head around the policy or
the costings because it's quite clear
the first Minister can this is all
starting to look like another Hamza
Yusuf disaster the man who couldn't get
the trains to run on time forced police
officers to Breaking Point and left our
NHS in crisis is now doing his best to
throw social care into chaos as well he
doesn't know if he's building a national
care service or a white elephant Hamza
Yusuf has no idea how much their
centralized care service is going to
cost or when this bureaucratic nightmare
will be ready or how it will improve the
situation for people who desperately
need better care the last thing the very
last thing our struggling Care Service
needs is an administrative overhaul
costing billions of pounds when it's
been start of cash from the front line
so wilhelms are Yusuf do the right thing
stop wasting taxpayers money and scrap
these plans altogether
first Minister quite incredible cleaning
officer that when we have given a pay
uplift to adult social care workers
Douglas Ross describes that as a waste
of money because every penny we spend on
social care is ensuring there's a
shooting that we left standards for
adult social care workers ensure we're
lifting standards for those who are in
receipt of care and while we do that yes
build a national care service that has
Fair work at its heart that builds a
national Care Service as ethical
commissioning at its heart so that the
profits from care aren't just gleamed
away into bank accounts in the Cayman
Islands something of course the
conservatives would like to see a
national care service that make sure we
put sectoral bargaining at its very
heart that's what we are committed to
and all of that of course in the midst
of the fact that we've had over a decade
of austerity from Douglas Ross's
conservative they've had a hard brexit
imposed upon us and of course the
disaster of the many budget which if we
had listened to Douglas Ross and gone
ahead with tax cuts for the wealthiest
our budget would be worth 500 million
pounds less so I'll take no lectures
about financial literacy nor indeed for
standards those who are working with our
care service from Douglas are also the
conservative
[Applause]
percent officer has just been announced
that interest rates will go up again
meaning higher mortgages all because of
touring economic chaos this in the same
week that the SMP launched their
campaign for another Tory government so
can I ask the first minister to put
aside his party's self-interest and be
honest
for Scotland they don't like the truth
providing officer
so can I ask the first minister to say
this party's self-interest and be honest
what is better for Scotland a labor
government auditory government
[Music]
and our own hands
and of course thank you
exceptionally Brave exceptionally pray
for anasawa to go on this topic of this
this week of all weeks because what we
have with Keir stormers labor party is
somebody who's refused to reverse every
single measure of Tori austerity what we
have with kierstarmer is of course an
individual who's reneged on his promise
to abolish tuition fees for students in
England what we have with care stammer
just yesterday as an individual who
refused to repeal cruel Tory legislation
such as the illegal migration Bill
Scotland doesn't need cruel harm for
policies imposed on it whether it's by a
politician that wears a blue tie or a
politician that wears a red tie what
Scotland needs is the full powers of an
independent nation to chart our own
course and get out of this unequal and
broken Union
sir
thank you there you have it ready you
can't answer the question Mr Sarma
we have visitors who've gathered to hear
the questions and answers we have people
tuned in Across the Nation who are also
Keen to do so and I would be grateful
well I appreciate your passion and
interest that we try and behave
ourselves with decorum Mr sarwar I think
you should be softer with them
presenting officers the first time
they've shown life in weeks so we should
we should appreciate the SMP back
Ventures and isn't it amazing that
they've shown life when it comes to
attacking the labor party a governing
party presenting officer a governing
party under investigation by the police
sexual misconduct allegations
whistleblowers being silenced division
on the back benches there's only one
party that looks like the Tories and
it's not us it's the SMP because the
first minister is so out of touch he
insults the intelligence of people
across Scotland labor will deliver a new
deal for working people and scrap the
Tory anti-trade Union laws labor will
deliver a publicly owned Energy company
some thing promised and failed to
deliver by the SNP liberally makes skull
and an r d Powerhouse not impose SNP
cuts on universities labor will bring
down people's bills with the proper
windfall tax not something the SNP and
the Tories support because that's the
change Scotland needs now I know the
first minister is still trying to find
his feet I know the job can be quite
confusing for him but so isn't it the
case that he prefers Authority
government because its cover for his own
incompetence first Minister you know you
know what you know what the SNP is
interested in presiding officer we're
not interested in just getting rid of
the Tories for a little while we weren't
ready to Victoria government forever and
the way we do that the way we do that is
of course for voting for our
independence we don't want to replace
Tory with Tory light or Tori with a pair
limitation of Tories and we know that
kierstama is lurching uh to the right
they're no more the little more than a
conservative tribute act just of course
last week labor are committed to keeping
Tori's anti-protest legislation in place
on tuition fees he's done a neck leg and
he's ditched of course his pledge to
make University
education free on progressive taxation
we are absolutely committed leading the
way in the Scottish government on
progressive taxation what does care
starmer say when it came to income tax
for the top five percent of earners he
said we're in a different situation now
I think we've got the highest tax burden
since World War II what about Railways
starmer of course was previously
committed to nationalizing uh Railways
now he says that a water Rail and other
services and I quote I take a pragmatic
approach rather than an ideological
approach so what I say to Anna sawar is
we are prepared to work with with any
political party in order to keep the
Tories out of number 10. why is he why
is uh Kiera stammer refusing to work
with a Scottish national party in order
to keep the Tories out of number 10. so
we are the most Progressive Party on
these islands but I say to Anna Sawa I
don't want rid of Tory governments just
for one year just for five years for one
election psycho we want rid of Tory
governments in Scotland for good
[Applause]
more interested in attacking labor than
getting Red Dot between government and
again it's interesting for anyone so
it's really interesting he didn't want
to talk to them first he didn't want to
talk about Paul ratings he didn't want
to talk about Paul rings with me why
approval rating
-12 competent 22 incompetent 40
trustworthy 18
untrustworthy 42 percent strong 19
weak thirteen nine percent doing well 19
doing badly 44 and the best of all the
best of all better than his predecessor
nine percent worse than his predecessor
41 appeal limitation of Nicholas surgeon
I'm not sure if that's a compliment
anymore but the SNP in the tour is two
sides of the same coin both one team
division both one thing chaos both one
thing to damage labor both wanting
Authority government all about saving
their jobs
of the people of Scotland because
Scotland is desperate for Change and
desperate get rid of two failing
governments and economically illiterate
and morally bankrupt Duty party are
dysfunctional and incompetent SMP
government so if you want change to
lower your bills to give more money into
people's pockets the air in Fire and
rehire to transform workers create
thousands of jobs then surely
Mr Sarah I'm sorry to disrupt this
session further but members are doing a
very very good job on that account and I
would be grateful if you could remember
the basic rules of the code of conduct
which require that we conduct ourselves
with courtesy and respect I am seeing
little of that and this is not
continuing Mr sarwar if you could please
put your question to the person they
don't like it the change is coming they
don't like it that they've been found
out they don't like it that they're
plummeting they don't like putting more
money into people's pockets with a
proper windfall tax they don't like
ending fire and rehire and scrapping the
active Trade Union laws they don't like
creating tenders
surely even the first Minister can see
that this is the change that Scotland
needs and it can only be delivered by a
labor government
[Music]
providing officer I'm grateful even you
had to stay up and to save the branch
manager the branch manager of the
Scottish labor party
and of course the reason why Scotland
won't trust here starmers because he is
a born-again breaks the tear remember of
course brexit that has caused economic
Devastation to this country and of
course anasawar said that he wants to
see a changing relationship with the
European Union we want to see a
relationship with the EU that means that
Scotland is back in the European Union
that we rejoin the European Union and
the only way to do that presiding
officer is of course as an independent
nation and an independent country but
here here is the real proof about the
fact that care stammer's labor party has
lurched again to the right the very
first major speaking event I went to was
at the stuc and Osama was there one
person that wasn't invited of course was
Kier starmar and of course the Dundee
TUC brought forward a motion the Dundee
TUC brought forward the motion
condemning care starmer's actions and
behaviors so they may well be led by a
party that is aimed after the founder of
the labor party but if Kia Hardy could
see the state the labor party then he
would be Burling in his grave presiding
officer
question number three Jillian Makai
to ask the first Minister whether the
Scottish government will consider a full
ban on disposable vaping products on
health and environmental grounds first
Minister we all give that consideration
consideration lettering of course of any
kind is unacceptable I share the members
concerns about the environmental impact
of single-use Vapes not to mention of
course the increased use amongst
children and young people who should not
have access to them of course in the
first place the minister for green
skills was the circular economy and
biodiversity has as zero-way Scotland to
examine the environmental impact of such
products and consider what the options
are to tackle the issues this review is
considering a whole range of possible
options including a ban any future
approach will be informed by the
findings of the review but I should make
it quite clear that the use of these
products is an issue we're taking very
seriously and nothing is off the table
at this stage
I thank the first Minister for that
answer and look forward to the
publication of the report commissioned
by the minister vaping has serious
environmental and health impacts that's
why campaigners like Les waste Laura The
Daily Record and a growing number of
councils have highlighted those harms
and I thank them all for their work
a full ban on disposable Vapes is needed
but does the first Minister agree with
me that there is much that can be done
ahead of a fill ban to reduce harm
keeping products away from public view
like cigarettes raising awareness of the
legal purchase age highlighting
disposable return points will the first
Minister join with me in calling on
retailers to step up to the plates and
Implement these measures first Minister
yes I will join in that call and we're
keen to work constructively with
retailers in this regard I understand
the many concerns around the
environmental but also the health
impacts of single-use Vapes that have
been raised by campaigners including
Less West Laura who Julian Makai
mentions and of course our local
government colleagues who I know also
take this issue extremely seriously we
have 15 councils who've now called for a
ban these as well as the issues the
member raises around retail
responsibilities are being looked at in
detail by the minister for the circular
economy and indeed the minister for
public health as part of the review of
the environmental impacts and in our
refresh tobacco action plan which will
be published in Autumn later this year
this will include further action on
education but also crucially on
enforcement as well I'll keep the member
updated on publication of that strategy
Mercedes for Alba
thanks to the work of local campaigners
in February this year Dundee City
Council supported Banning disposable
Vapes and called for a national ban from
the Scottish government so as there is
already local support for such a ban can
I ask the first Minister what
consideration the Scottish government
has given to introducing a pilot ban on
disposable Vapes in Dundee to help
develop a model for a national ban
I think it's very well one of the off
consideration as a reference to my last
responses around about 15 councils who
have called for a ban but I'm not
surprised to see Dundee City Council SMP
at Dundee City Council of course leading
the way in this regard so I'm more than
happy to consider the issue of a
potential pilot but I do think it is
important the work that we've initiated
through the review is allowed to happen
and I will assure that that work of
course is published but we take really
immediate action because this is a an
issue of growing concern both for the
environmental impact is having but
clearly for some of the health impacts
it's having to
question number four Fiona Hislop to ask
the first Minister what the Scottish
government's position is on the view of
the children and young people's
commissioner for Scotland that NHS
Lothian should review its children's
rights impact assessment of the decision
to end the youth Navigator program which
operates at St John's Hospital first
Minister the hospital youth navigates a
pilot will continue to be delivered by
Medics against violence and NHS Partners
at the Queen Elizabeth Hospital for
Children in Glasgow alongside the adult
Navigator program in nine hospitals
across Scotland that Navigators are key
support workers who help individuals
presenting at hospitals with multiple
complex needs to access those Support
Services I understand that no decision
about further future funding has yet
been taken at this time and that NHS
lothians are evaluating all of their
youth work provision in hospitals
including the pilot that's been
referenced by Fiona Hislop and a
confirmed a children's rights and
well-being impact assessment will be
undertaken on those proposed options
final report is expected to be discussed
at the children and young people's
program board at the end of this month
as the first Minister has acknowledged
the youth Navigator is supported by
Medics against violence who have
announced that funding will end at the
end of June it offers a youth work based
community outreach service to vulnerable
young people at age 12 to 16 accessed at
a time of presentation at St John's
Hospital in West Hills as well as the
sick kids hospital in Edinburgh does he
acknowledge that having debated a
trauma-informed approach to Services
only on Tuesday in this chamber that
preventative Youth Work such as offered
by the successful youth Navigator
program should be supported not
withdrawn and that are full child impact
assessment would have flied that adverse
childhood experiences often present as a
crisis on Hospital presentation and area
support and intervention actioned
quickly can be most effective first
Minister Fiona his law makes very
important Point indeed and one that I
fully subscribed to particularly my
roles in Justice and health previously
of course taking that preventative
trauma-informed approach particularly
Through The Navigators program it can
make a difference and has made a
difference to many young people in this
case in NHS at lothians so I do value
the importance of the service Fiona
Hislop is correct absolutely correct and
saying that the most effective approach
as I say to dealing with these issues
issues is to take a trauma informed and
preventative approach I had a reference
in my previous answer that these matters
are under review and that of course when
it comes to the final provision of Youth
Services in NHS Lothian there is
confirmation that children's right and
well-being impact assessment will be
undertaken but I'm uh I will ensure that
the cabinet secretary for Health and
Social care makes representations to NHS
Lothian on the important issues that
Fiona haslop has raised Sue Weber first
Minister scrapping the service will have
a devastating effect effect on
vulnerable children and young people
across the Lothian region the QE
Hospital is hardly accessible
many other Youth Work Services have lost
funding and statutory service like cams
are at Breaking Point cutting back on
youth work is the wrong course of action
and will just store up problems for the
future
we hear so often about the preventative
approach being championed by the
Scottish government and this project
does the exactly that so why are we even
considering cutting it
first Minister okay again can I say to
sue web I do agree with the approach in
relation to preventative funding and of
course there's government funds Medics
against violence it's an excellent
organization who have had the pleasure
of meeting a number of times over the
years we fund them to the tune of 337
000 pounds in terms of this financial
year and do deliver a variety of
violence prevention activity including
the core activity to deliver and support
the National Hospital Navigator program
I go back to the answer that I reference
to Fiona Hislop this is a decision NHS
Lothian are reviewing they are looking
at the youth service provision in the
round and of course they will do that
important impact assessment that Fiona
Hislop has called for and more than
happy that the government make
representations 10 HS log in on the back
of what has been said in the chamber
today but ultimately of course this will
be a decision that for NHS lovian to
take and I would expect them to do the
full impact Assessments in this regard
question number five Pam Gossel thank
you presiding officer to ask the first
Minister what action the Scottish
government is taking to support
qualities in universities in Scotland
first minister
colleges and universities make it
crucial and unique contribution to
Scotland we're investing nearly 2
billion pounds in the sectors each year
through the Scottish funding Council
when we make this funding flexible uh
where possible I recognize the
challenges I recognize the pressures
that colleges and universities are
currently facing and of course we will
continue to engage with the Scottish
funding Council as well as the sectors
directly to ensure that institutions are
financially stable
the first Minister for that um answer
two weeks ago the SMP government took a
dagger to the heart of colleges and
universities by cutting 46 million of
funding that was only announced in
December with no warning and no
consultation when the Scottish budget
was announced the Scottish government
trumped a 12.7 million increase for
higher education five months on from the
budget this is now 7.3 million cash cut
between Financial years since then I've
also received a letter from the city of
Glasgow College stating that their
intention to begin a process of 75
compulsive redundancies presiding
officer despite claiming education was
her number one priority the previous
first Minister Nicholas Sergeant field
Scotland's young people so can I ask the
first Minister what are they going to do
to prevent history from repeating itself
first Minister when it comes back to the
question of the former first Minister I
can remind you that there are more young
people people from areas of deprivation
going to University now than there ever
have been before that is down to the
legacy of nephilosturgeon we're closing
the poverty related attainment Gap
because of the actions of the former
first minister in terms of the savings
that we've had to make and these are
difficult decisions that we have to make
I'm not going to downplay uh the
significance and the effect that that
saving will have on both the colleges
and University sector but just to put it
into some context is 2.3 percent of the
two billion pound budget for further
education and for higher education in 23
24 but why are we why do we have to make
that saving we had to make it because
every single party I think rightly stood
here and demanded the Scottish
government intervened demanded that we
helped to assist the local government in
relation to settling the teachers paid
dispute an additional 320 million had to
be found to do that it doesn't just grow
in the proverbial Magic Money three so
tough decisions had to be made we were
upfront about that so we'll take those
tough decisions we certainly won't take
lectures from a from a conservative
member of course their party the reason
why of course we are facing the
financial constraints on the Scottish
Public Finance it's kind of remind Pam
go so because of sky-high inflation
because of the decisions taken by a
conservative government our Scottish
finances last year were worth 1.7
billion pounds less at Peak inflation
because of the economic Carnage our
party uh inflicted upon Scotland so yes
we will take the tough decisions needed
certainly won't take any lectures on
financial and economic literacy from the
conservative party
Sally mapstone the head of University of
Scotland described this SMP government's
policy on universities as manage decline
so why does the first Minister think
this multi-million pound cut to the
University's budget is going to reverse
that managed decline first Minister I I
don't agree with that characterization
I'm more than happy to meet with Team
Sally mapstone and other university and
college principals in the course of the
coming weeks and months and years to
come because I do take our views very
very seriously indeed in terms of the
the characterization of managed decline
can I just remind whether any of course
at the latest higher education stats
sure that a record number of Scottish
drama style students are studying at
Scottish universities we have some of
the best universities in the world
world-class universities that's because
of course of the excellent uh excellent
initiatives by those universities the
excellent education they provide but
also it's down to the funding that the
Scottish government has put in to a
higher education further education
sectors for many many years to come so
I'm more than happy to engage with the
university and college principles but I
simply do not accept this manage decline
when we have such world-class
universities such as St Andrews that are
being funded by the Scottish government
question number six Katie Clark thank
you presiding officer and I refer to my
entry in the register of members
interests to ask the first Minister what
the Scottish government's position is on
the potential impact of the proposed
timetable reductions by scotrail on
efforts to secure a modal shift from car
to train first minister
my understanding is that as a result of
scotriel's new May 2023 timetable the
number of daily Services Remains the
Same with no overall reduction and the
resources are being focused on areas to
better serve current demand as a result
Peak trains and School connections have
been prioritized in order to support
that very modal shift that Katie Clark
refers to I want to make Scotland's
public transport system more accessible
I want to make it more available I want
to make it more affordable that is why I
confirmed last month that the six-month
pilot to remove Peak Fair peak time
fares from scottrill services will start
in October of this year this
intervention unprecedented in the UK
real sector will also enable officials
to gather evidence right across
transport modes for the fair fairs
review and to inform future proposals
while of course encouraging importantly
modal shift Katie Clark
I thank the first Minister for his
answer however despite the Scottish
government's goal of reducing car use by
20 by 2020. scottrill is proposing to
cut many train services including many
commuter services such as the 742 a.m
Larks to Glasgow service will the first
Minister look at the case for
maintaining the 742 large to Glasgow
committed service and really agree with
me that we need to do far more to
encourage people to use the railways
rather than cars if we are to achieve
our climate change Target and will he
carry out an assessment of how the
timetable changes being proposed by
scottrail will impact on meeting these
goals first minister
I agree with the absolute underlying
premise of kitty Clark's question it's
so important that we make public
transport available affordable as best
we possibly can and as accessible as we
possibly can in order to get that modal
shift away from Carr uh to public
transport in terms of the very
operational matters that she refers to
will ensure that transport secretary
does engage with Scorpio but they are
operational matters for scotrail in
terms of the 742 from lives to Glasgow
and my understanding is that it's been
replaced by the 754 from a droson to
Glasgow an additional train has been
added to the timetable from addressing
to Glasgow departing at 7 26th the May
2023 timetable also provide Journey
saving times for those passengers
traveling on the air to Glasgow route
and following on from customer feedback
the adroson and live services will never
call it stations in the garnetic valley
to improve connection so there has been
changes that have been made right across
the timetable uh directly influenced by
user feedback what I would say to Katie
Clark is she's absolutely right we do
need to continue to do more in order to
ensure that public track that model
shift happens between car and public
transport and that's why I'm really
pleased and one of my first Nights At
first Minister was to announce the
beginning of the pilot to abolish peak
real fares that run for six months from
October this year John Mason
thank you can the first Minister confirm
that passenger numbers have not returned
to pre-covered levels partly because
people are working at home and that
means a shortfall in cash for either the
railways or the government can you
confirm how that shortfall is being made
up
first Minister John is absolutely right
to raise the issues that he does clearly
passenger numbers are still recovering
from the pandemic so income levels are
still down but Scotland's rail operators
are also of course having to meet those
really high inflationary cross costs
that are affecting every single business
every single person right now all of
that of course impacts on our real
budget but I understand that the cost of
implementing the May 2023 timetable
change is hopefully projected to be
neutral it's difficult difficult to
accurately assess the exact Financial
impact of Passenger numbers that have
not yet returned to pre-covered levels
but it's good that demand continues too
even if it's incrementally continues to
increase and is currently recovered to
over two-thirds of pre-covet levels
clearly we want Scotland's publicly
controlled Railways to succeed both in
the short and the long term scottriel
has been working hard through a range of
promotions in recent months to encourage
more people to travel by train not least
because of contribution real can make
and should make and will make to
addressing climate change and current
transport emissions
moved to General and constituency
supplementaries and I call Claire
Adamson thank you very much preserving
officer following the tragic death of
Hima Carson Mallorca due to a suspected
carbon monoxide leak in a holiday home I
know the chamber's thoughts and
condolences will be with Mr carsey's
friends loved ones and especially his
wife no recovering the dangers of carbon
monoxide are frequently a subject for
the cross-party group on accident
prevention and safety awareness
regulations vary greatly both here and
abroad so does the first Minister agree
that members of the public should
consider heating the advice from
organizations such as rospa and the
safer tourism foundation and consider a
carbon monoxide alarm as essential
holiday packing first Minister yes I do
agree with that of course I'm my
thoughts are with of course the family
of Jamie Carsey and indeed of course
with his wife Mary who remains my
understanding is remains in a very
serious condition in Hospital of course
with their friends their family and the
community that will be deeply saddened
and rocked by these as events a carbon
monoxide detector can give people a
important life-saving warning of a
faulty Appliance in Scotland it is of
course a legal requirement to include a
carbon monoxide detect on any room with
a carbon fueled appliance fitting one of
these detectors is vital for safety it
could literally quite literally save
your life so I would encourage everyone
to find out about the importance of
being aware of the signs of carbon
monoxide poisoning and the actions that
can keep they can keep them safe as well
and you can find more information on an
all one word gas safety register dot Co
dot UK sorry I'll say that again gas
safe register dot Co dot UK so more
information can be found but I hope of
course that that merely Somerville the
wife of Jim Carson continues hopefully
to recover and my thoughts again with
her and the family of Jim Carsey Douglas
Lumsden a presiding officer yesterday
the fight to save six libraries on
bucksburn swimming pool in Aberdeen
moved to the courts will the first
Minister contact the SMP administration
at Aberdeen city council and tell them
to get a grip listen to the people
they're meant to serve and not fight
them in the courts or is this yet
another example of the SMP failing the
people of the Northeast
um but before the fresh Minister
responds I will remind members again
that questions to the first Minister
should be put on matters for which the
Scottish government have General
responsibility and of course it is the
smp-led government that has increased
funding for local government and of
course it would be Douglas Lumsden who
would be the first one to complain if we
interfered and intervened in local
decisions that are being made what I
won't do is of course comment on any
potential live court proceedings that
have taken place but we have increased
funding to local government and of
course we respect the decisions that are
being made by local government and is
their right to make those decisions of
course under Section 163 of the Local
Government Act 1973 so we'll continue to
make sure we fund local government but
we won't what we won't do is intervene
and interfere in those locally made
decisions Monica Lennon
this evening alongside the stuc and to
send email I'm hosting a parliamentary
reception to celebrate the Food For
Thought campaign and the positive impact
of universal free skill meals Scotland
all msps are invited and we hope that
the first Minister can join to hear
directly from young people
how access to Universal free School
meals is reducing poverty inequality and
stigma further to comments he reportedly
made in the Daily Record can the first
Minister provide an update on the
rollout of universal free School meals
and primary schools and on the pilot
program to be launched in secondary
schools first Minister I could say to um
and for others that have an interest in
this issue of course the SNP LED
government is the party of universalism
that is why of course we abolished a
tuition fee something that KIA stammer's
labor party of course are not going to
be doing that's why we're the party of
the baby books it's why we're the party
of course that has introduced Universal
free School meals P1 to P5 and yes of
course stood in a manifestal commitment
and remain committed to the Future
rollout in terms of P6 and p7 of course
looking at a Pilot as well in secondary
schools I simply made the point and I
continued to meet the point and I made
this point at the anti-poverty summit
that we will look at what more we can do
around progressive taxation that we will
because of the economic Carnage that has
been inflicted Upon Us by the UK
government have to look at making really
tough decisions we will have to look at
targeting of course across a range of
potential policy areas there's not a
there's not a conflict between
universalism and being targeted yes
there are some uh there's some rights
that should be Universal such as the
right to a free education to Free
University education they are rights
they are not benefits they are not
luxury at the same time we should
absolutely make sure we're being
targeted at where we can such as for
example the Scottish child payment that
game-changing Intervention which is
helping the poorest in our society so we
are the party that is both of course the
party of universalism but also the party
that makes sure we target our resources
towards those that absolutely need the
most help particularly in the face of a
UK government that is that is inflicting
harm upon harm on the poorest in our
society
start the shooting
presiding also uncontrolled Bracken is
the perfect breeding ground for ticks
ticks which carry diseases that infect
humans diseases such as the debilitating
Lyme's disease so will the first
Minister end the delay and instruct the
authorization of acid locks acid locks
the the only effective treatment in
order to control Bracken and given that
time is running out both for its
procurement and use in the available
season will he do that straight away
and if not does he appreciate that the
outcome will be likely the widespread
infection of many human beings with this
Dreadful Lyme's disease first minister
I'll of course look into the issue that
Fergus raises the serious issue the
Fergus Ewing raises that the Scottish
government does recognize uh the
concerns about the potential risk of
uncontrolled Bracken the difficulties
associated with its control particularly
here uh in Scotland is Ashley locks as a
herbicide which has no current EU or UK
authorization there is a specific
legislative conditions that must be made
in order to Grant an emergency
authorization of the product to ensure
that high level of protection for human
health and for the environment Health
HSE is responsible for assessing
emergency authorization applications
right across the UK against the
legislative requirements the Scottish
government considered and promptly
responded to hse's recommendation that
HSC my understanding is we'll issue the
decision to the applicant once all other
UK governments have responded Scottish
government is aware of the importance of
effective pesticides when used as part
of an integrated approach and our
position is very much Guided by
regulation and importantly crucially by
scientific evidence
okay
grateful for presenting officer this
week three quarters of people surveyed
said that they think we should meet our
domestic energy needs from UK oil and
gas production rather than Imports this
government's energy strategy
specifically includes a presumption
against new exploration and production
in the North Sea now yesterday this
first Minister tried to please both
sides of this debate yet carefully
committed to neither so here's the
chance to get off the fence given the
need for energy security to protect
thousands of Scottish jobs and the
climate benefits of local production
will he remove from the energy strategy
this government's intention to close
down the North Sea first Minister
what what the government will do
presenting officer is of course listen
to those consultation responses it just
closed a couple of days ago we've had
over 1500 responses we'll analyze them
carefully but be no doubt at all
presenting officers that we are
absolutely committed to a just
transition a transitional away from oil
and gas but importantly increasingly for
our economy and for our planet to make
sure we unleash that potential of the
green economy so we have to make sure we
live up to our climate obligations both
domestic targets and international
obligations we have to make sure that we
are playing our energy security again
domestically but also internationally
too but what we absolutely won't do is
what the Liam cares conservatives did to
the mining and steel communities the
1970s and 80s we won't throw a single
worker in the Northeast on the scrap
Heap during this just transition process
so what you will see from the Scottish
government when it comes to unlocking
our green potential is action and what
we're seeing from the UK government is
complete and utter in action for example
failing to make any meaningful progress
on investment in the Scottish cluster or
indeed in the acorn project in
particular completing utter abject
failure and inaction from the UK
government whereas we will take action
to make sure we unleash the potential of
the dean economy not just in the
Northeast but for the whole of Scotland
and that is important because we want to
of course invest and unlock the
potential for our economy but it's also
a moral imperative to ensure the
sustainability of our planet in the
future a new baby
but thank you president officer the
economy secretary has now said he would
like to see Ferguson Marine return to
private ownership as soon as possible
the GMB rightly said the ministry of
Defense work from Bae is a sign of
confidence in the workforce and the
Scottish government should follow suit
by developing a plan for the direct
Award of smaller vessels with robust
oversight in place the GMB a rate
changing ownership and plunging the
workforce into more uncertainty is not
the solution it's important we listen to
them in fact if their warnings have been
listened to earlier perhaps we wouldn't
be have the Fiasco we have now there's a
first Minister not accept that given
this whole mess is of the government's
making it's the government's job to
clean it up first minister
of course the government stepped in and
saved hundreds of jobs on the quite save
hundreds of dollars I make no apology
for that of course they have undoubtedly
been challenges which the government has
fronted up but when it comes to gmb's uh
letter in this issue public versus uh
private ownership what Neo gray said has
been in the government's position for a
long time it's always been the intention
of the Scottish government to return
Ferguson's Marine two private ownership
indeed this was made clear when we
announced the yard being taken into
public ownership in the very first place
there's not much having seen the GMB
later there's not much in the GMB letter
that we disagree with we want to work
with them with a wider Workforce to
secure the best possible future in the
outcome for the art because we do
absolutely have faith in that Workforce
and in the future of the art investment
in the yard is is about more than just
profitability it's important of course
as that is it's also about the retention
of skills around jobs manufacturing
capability and these will be key
considerations in any decision over the
future of the yard any deal to see the
yard return to private ownership must
prevent value for money but let me be
absolutely unequivocal about it it must
also ensure it continues the good work
on Fair work which is at the heart of
everything this government does yeah
thank you that concludes fresh ministers
questions the next item of business is a
member's business debate in the name of
Rachel Hamilton and there'll be a short
suspension to allow those leaving the
chamber and public gallery to do so
foreign